each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hi my name is Pam an apartment i'm from
the School of Health and Rehab sciences
of the universe of Pittsburgh and my
project is on personal health records
the first time I read about my life
and read Jayme's paper I thought
that would do those guys are really
embraces and but the more I learned
about it it makes sense and looks like
doable so my the idea of my project is
very simple if my life is try to record
for everything how about just doing it
for the subset of it so any thing that
relate to health and I thought that
since help is a subset of life that must
be really a much simpler than then my
life and it's or not that that's
not true and and then imitation is the
highest form of flattery I name the
project is my half beats and hopefully
Jane will sue me for that copyright
infringement so I'll yes it's still not
running so I'll talk a bit about a
person like how they got personal record
england just a brief background on it
what it is and the the curtain states of
it and then the plan for the project and
also report that the progress so far
okay the type of half record that we
know usually called electronic health
record and the difference between
personal health record and electronic
health records EHR is usually providers
centric meaning that it's owned by
provider to support provider food so
it's owned by hospitals or doctors to
support their job and that's why usually
billing and reimbursement will be first
to be automatic
then clinical and anything related to to
care would be the lives because anything
riff to to financial relief is it's very
important more important than then the
the clinical or personal record and one
patient as a result usually one patient
have many electronic health record
scattered around many providers or many
hospitals and know what it's are easily
has everything and as I mentioned that
pH are easily small patient centric and
so pH sarees consists of all ESR add
personality personal integrated
information sort of like if i use
wearable monitoring devices like go was
it I want to monitor how many steps I I
think today or how many miles I run
today and then things like that and also
diets and and medication
over-the-counter medication and also if
I want to to put in my weblog so usually
appears our treatment info and and and
and and pcs information it is is
perceived through those kind
performances combined will will lead to
active more active participants of the
patient in their own health and this is
the the belief why is our is very
important as you might have known that
the PHR is getting more popular in the
last probably few years to three years
or so and and this is the resume benefit
is to improve because the more health
information with the more availability
of the Hat informationally to improve
patient safety and then also consumer
will get more info on under teaching
making of their own
and all the legally electronic health
record or patient ethic of this owned by
patient but in reality useless was owned
by by the provider ended by having
maintaining their own record hopefully
there's more sense of ownership and the
patient become the copilot of their own
care and is that true and a poll thing
just recently published his that is not
really a large study study of from the
Palo Alto foundation and if it to know
that yes it's true that the timely
access to and that's for very simple
personal health record like health lab
has and and a simple record of the visit
with the doctor say bleep to to
improvement in patients behavior me
meaning that patient change their
behavior as a result of that and one
fifth or twenty percent of the patient's
teach them and that's the sort of
anecdotal confession of some of the
patients that by knowing you know their
blood lipids and knowing that the blood
pressure early they can adjust the or
cholesterol level each as their their
diet and one important feature that is
provided by ph are the current bhr is
the connection with with with the
doppler with the provider and so not
that patients are all felt more
connected and and they didn't abuse the
privilege of pilot by clogging the
covers with with spam or any unnecessary
email
and this is the iclicker give you an
example of this is provider-based
personal health paper so this is
personal havoc are provided by by health
care provider in this case is my
institution UPMC in pittsburgh and this
is my own record so we we have health
summary there including lab tests and
also we have reminder let's say you have
to do cholesterol testing or screening
in the next three months oh it's already
oh how did it and then all any other
fractionations I have to go through it
also provided here we can see the
messaging I can communicate with my
primary care about about my about recent
visit so about my problem and yeah this
is an example of email and this is
another example from Palo Alto Palo Alto
Medical Foundation and as we can see
it's almost exactly the same and and the
the the features they are almost the
same house recent visits test results
messaging and appointments and well the
the problem is this is almost there's no
no no innovation whatsoever is basically
what they do is provide a subset of have
information that they have to page and
that with a simple surface like that
it's or not you have a high impact
already so the the goal of the project
is to move from this too much more
advanced personal half a car w we will
record everything get rid of to health
and this is the the optimal
characteristic of EHR is from the
american medical informatics association
white paper first it has to be lifelong
and comprehensive so meaning that
it should consist of any data that
relate to health and from you know and
and it's lifelong so of course the
current EHR doesn't doesn't have this
visa and then it has to be accessible
from any place anywhere so the any place
any fine so the the optimal health
record should be well to make it easy
would be web-based and then it must
provide half management tool to help
position with without record with and
could help them maintaining their own
half and then of course the fourth one
is of course my friends here and then
the fifth one is book is very important
the patient have four full control as to
who have access to it and what data that
he also wanted to share and so let's
move on to through my life is my health
is sorry it will be lifelong and love
you dip below so the the first challenge
is how to integrate all in a multi-modal
data signal from images email web and
how to manage it in in in an integrated
database is similar in a way similar to
my life page and then the difference is
that in healthcare standards attributes
are everything so there are standards
for that the pier does it look like this
one and the beta the database should
contain these fields and so that's the
first chance that we have so our
challenge is how to design schema that
need suspended but also a user friendly
and easy enough to be useful by users
and of course will add a lot of personal
things so many personal generate data
and then also helping users raising
their own health and then another thing
that will be added to it is
communication including email and nbsp
have been experiment
with the with video conferencing between
in this case we use it for a fellow
rehab between patient and rehab
therapist we will also add video
conferencing to the data as well and
then we'll address the privacy and
patient control well later on in the
project well I it because half is a
subset of life and I can just easily use
my life its shell and then database and
then you just implement it and it's
renowned that our need this doesn't
allow that I at the beginning I asked
Tim well can I have the source code and
well so now that not at this moment well
because we we need much much more
flexibility so we we end up we decided
that we have to build on our own and so
that create a lot of problem and so we
have to put it on the ground up and but
because there are a lot of advanced
features from my life we would
like to to borrow the ideas from my
language or even use components or part
of my life which said that we can use
and all the sort of you know the stories
of record management is similar and then
web and email capture capture are also
similar video capture is is new and then
we use also the same mechanism in the
database like start procedure also the
way we view the data up quite similar as
well and so so we'd like to record you
know the doctor's visit for example or
therapist visit and then email and in
this case on the email that related to
health
so please subset of what tim is going to
do and then sometimes when in my case i
browse way up and then it's my infra it
lived to my interest and i want to save
that because i want i want to save that
web page for example it through exercise
or vitamin things like that so we will
also and then also in one of our project
we have a therapy session and then
personal get that money of this problem
with this i don't know if any of you
work on this is it's not that every half
monitoring devices their own they have
their own proprietary data capture and
they don't want you to really look at
the data because we want to sell the
surface of managing your data so that's
that's the problem that we have right
now and for example for the PPO even for
simple things like we do neither because
we thought that a pyramid will be very
simple and then we can just capture the
gear that's not that but there if you
plug into the computer it look good
directly to their website and then the
data will go to their database and
there's no way to interrupt it and then
and then capture the data and in between
and then we this is a real video
conferencing that we have and then also
will also have work wearable the
difference if we're about the media and
all this one is the one that we we
android by ourself we are no way is
similar to my life page but oh and we
would like to view the record you know
based on a data type and then the half
information type as well as the timeline
is similar to to my to my life page so
the progress so far we have to design
the schema based on the standard scott
continua t of Carrick
that's the standard is being approved by
sdn and then pressing integrating
multi-modal get us if the database in
data sets in the death of this and then
how to present it me using we follow the
idea from from Crime Line from the univ
of maryland and then on the personal
side capturing web and and email as well
as capturing from wearable devices in
this dispute anita and then on the
communication side we have captured a
video conferencing and then also from
email and these are the type of record
so for example there's a personal
information and then half condition and
then have history and the administrative
stuff like providers and insurance and
this is what what it looks like so we
have time over here in this case monthly
we can choose the monthly or quarterly
annually or even daily and then this is
the half acre data we have and then we
can choose which one to show and in in
weights the the interface is similar to
to my life mates and we have caps over
there one of the challenges is to
separate which half they could should be
update very very frequently and which
have record shop like the Fitzpatrick
meaning that for example you you want to
change insurance monthly you prob'ly
change engines at moves every year
probably every several years or you
change providers usually only only once
in in a few years the same thing with
with well personal information is quite
static and half conditions usually is so
we organized it based on the frequency
of the from from the very active to to
the very sad book one
and this is an example we can save set
the the timeline from what way to your
date and then also presents images and
and web over there and we also have
slider over there similar to the one in
timeline and this is example of we only
select a few types of halfway cutta
cutta instead of everything and we
provide previewer in this is a preview
of a CT scan this is a preview of email
and this preview of a web page and we
can also adjust the size or the of the
grid from from small three to two medium
create and these are we provide
facilities two minutes at different type
of information and I have the paper with
me you can fight if you interested I
won't do them over here because it will
be faster to split doing screenshot and
it won't crash well the as we can see
here the the the way we organize big I
still using document base we everything
there are document one of the challenge
that we found is that in in in half way
that we we have a document based data as
well as theta like continuous data if
you want to monitor what's the progress
with your jogging in the last in the
past few months gets confused a tiny we
want to compare that over time for
example that that would be
you know wouldn't be correctly
represented using the document piece
like this so one of the next work that
we plan to do is to have event-based
personal steamer so that for example if
you have your tag messes with medical
condition oh you you visit a doctor and
as a result of that doctor's order CPS
can order a certain tasks that the all
the documents or data related to that
event should be sipping organized
together so that's what we tend to do
and actually the original schema looks
like that but in the initial
implementation we up for the of course
for the for the easy scheme offers and
oops also everything in here is has time
as she mentioned so even half condition
we can track it down of a crime as well
or because this one has to be lifelong
record so if you change providers have
you changed insolence we can also track
it down and ok so now so the next thing
we plan to populate this with with real
data so we will recruit volunteers for
that and well we have been using our own
data for this at this point and then
chilling the schema to first to use
health event pays in set of documents at
this point for example yeah if you have
CP scan oh why do you have CT scan what
what event is is really good at good HCP
scan for example and had more and more
enriched or data and then the challenge
another challenge is to strike a balance
between
the reason why it's time that is
important in health care is that most of
this data like CT scan doctors racing
for example we will get it from
providers so we we need to confirm to to
the standard technology adopted by the
community or if you want to send the
data to other providers that we should
be able to do that so but if you see the
standard this is very you know it's very
boring and it's also not user friendly
so that you need to strike a balance
between how to make it easy for consumer
to use it but it's also follow the
standard and then as we get to my life
it's one of the feature that we'd like
to have is we probably an advanced ntfs
promotion from the current version of my
life beats through to have intelligent
record collection of water so if I know
that this this document is in x-ray then
then promoted through to x-ray pie for
example instead of annotating it
manually by ourselves boy this email is
other type of document than the system
should be able to to classify it
automatically and then capture more
wearable devices as I mention the
challenges that no but no wearable
device manufacturer one you to have your
own data I think the reason is because
wearable device is very inexpensive and
the only business model that makes sense
other than selling it is to managing the
data and then the challenge of managing
data points and document in the same
time all numerical overtime talk data
and documents in the same time and then
we have included email and and video
conferencing in this but we haven't
really fired what's the pathway for
communication to be done then the kernel
version of the current no person of
personal health a puppet that provided
by by hospital so you have to do this on
their own side she didn't have any any
control even have an ethernet controller
paper in this life so you have to log on
to their side and then to communicate
wit with the daughters and our idea is
to use our own email how own video
conferencing through the communicate and
then you you have the tape and you can
you can start the day down you're on
your own personal hell think so that's
basically it thank you any questions
legally yes so the data is produced in
but I think it's very rare for patient
to to have that electronically send to
you right now say yes yeah that's mmm
but right now because personal have
record is getting more and more popular
and also there are a lot of efforts
right now on the part of providers and
in government for sharing the data as
part of actually new legislation put so
at least it will be easier for for
consumer through perceive their own data
from providers all the legalese is is is
possible right now or it's legally as
yours but it's very difficult to do that
practica in in practice yes the for this
to work we we need to get the data lot
of data from from right from different
providers
apparently yes that's why standard is
important in this case so when we plan
to put more Delta for that as well to
through who imported and also to export
data and in standard format yeah yes
best dozen interesting yes yes in
addition to automatic wearable automatic
caption from wearable devices will
provide where consumer maintain their
own for example jogging some device can
provide you with with that but if you
don't want to to use that device you can
enter you know how many miles I job
today and and you can track it down
offer over time and I'm failed to
mention that there are many sort of
providers figure database or patient
record database provider available so
you can you can rent a space for example
with with the webmd you can rent space
to maintain your own personal health
record so and I think quite a few
services right now available as well as
personally have records software so you
can you can buy the software and
maintain in Europe and all of the server
is still very simple it's basically sort
of access therapies and provide and you
can record the basic thing similar to
the one provided by by hospitals or
insurers
so no where near like you can record you
can you can store everything fine